[Musique]
mais carlo au sud est du texas est la
plus lisse panique des villes
américaines 90% de ses 150 mille
habitants parlent l'espagnol
nous sommes dans la vallée du rio grande
et coller à la frontière avec le mexique
mais karine est devenue une autoroute
demi gramme
[Musique]
ils arrivent ici tous les jours par
centaines on les croise partout dans les
rues
au centre d'accueil à la gare d'autobus
prêts à commencer une vie meilleure
n'aura guère à 24 ans vient du honduras
avec son fils bryson trois ans il vise
le new jersey ils ont mis trois mois
pour arriver
80% des migrants qui passe par mais
karine traverse légalement comme nora
ils réclament l'asile politique
parce qu'ils se disent persécutés dans
leur pays abellino arrive aussi du
honduras où il n'avait plus de travail
mais morel dans ce numéro c'est
parlementaire ni n'a qu'à l'époque il
nous montre le bracelet imposées par les
autorités
les services d'immigration s'assure
ainsi qu'à bellino reviennent en cours
pour savoir s'il pourra rester aux états
unis
tous ces migrants sont accueillis à mes
karlen parser norman telle déroute a ici
des familles entières reçoivent
vêtements nourriture et conseils avant
de poursuivre leur route
cent mille migrants depuis quatre ans
ont bénéficié de l'aide de ce petit
centre qui déborde sur norma temps de
leur redonner courage et dignité
[Musique]
on était tous le fermier chat mais le
lui n'apprécie pas du tout ces
immigrants encore moins ceux qui
traversent illégalement sa ferme longe
le rio grande et à la frontière du
mexique groupe
[Musique]
il en veut aussi aux gardes frontières
qui détruit selon lui ces récoltes en
pourchassant les clandestins chat mais
le nous montre où il a vu un migrant se
noyer il y a trente ans
au même moment deux hommes et une femme
surgissent près de la rivière ils
marchent vers nous l'air hagard
apeurée traquer en elle ces clandestins
arrivent du honduras du guatemala et du
mexique
ils viennent de traverser le rio grande
et à la nage
ils ont faim froid et soif
ils nous demandent de l'aide qu'on ne
peut leur offrir
nous pourrions y dernier être arrêté par
les gardes frontières
non loin de là s'installe la puissante
armée américaine mille soldats
débarquent dans la région à la demande
du président pour protéger la frontière
ces militaires semblent s'ennuyer pour
l'instant surtout que l'invasion annoncé
par donald trump n'aura pas lieu au
texas
la caravane de migrants se dirige plutôt
vers la californie
michel les dirigeants du camp peine à
justifier leur présence massive
ils n'ont selon la loi aucun pouvoir
pour arrêter les migrants non nous
n'avons pas besoin de l'armée dit le
maire de may carles
il n'ya pas d'invasion ici tout ça
ajoute-t-il
c'est du spectacle james darling est
fier de sa ville qui aident les migrants
mais câline dit il est une des villes
les plus sécuritaires aux états unis
[Musique]
comment avoir peur 10h norma pimentel
d'êtres humains qui souffrent la peur et
la violence se trouvent surtout du côté
du mexique où les cartels de drogue
terrorisent les populations les migrants
croisé près de la rivière ont fui cette
violence il nous supplie de ne pas les
dénoncer
ils se sont fait dire qu'il pouvait se
cacher dans une maison tout près d'ici
[Musique]
c'est toujours la même histoire constate
le fermier
on leur a encore menti ces trois
migrants ont franchi la frontière
illégalement et pourrait être déporté il
se sauve en courant à la fois si près et
si loin de cette terre promise dont ils
ont tant rêver